like
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah. Continuing
in the chapter of purification
from the book of purification or the
chapter regarding the etiquets of
relieving oneself. self in the book of
purification of
We
will be Allah.
[Silence]
on the authority of
who narrates that the messenger of Allah
said, "If any of you is to your mate,
then he is not to hold his member
with his right hand, nor is he to use
his right hand to wipe or purify
himself. self. This is again going and
following falling into line with the
pattern of
that the general principle is that the
right has precedence over the left in
all matters concerning purification.
ation etc. And so here the prophet
sallall alaihi wasallam
specifies that is impermissible for a
person to urinate and to use his right
hand to do so
to use his right hand to do so.
Nor that a person should wipe himself or
clean himself after relieving himself
using the right hand as well.
And it is permissible for a person to
purify himself using water or stones
or anything of the likes
and water is
you know better. Water is better.
So often times the scholars of f they
differentiate between
using water and using stones or
something dry. When a person uses
something dry they call it.
When someone uses water it's called
anette.
And either way what the point is that a
person clean himself.
And this can be done either with
something dry or something wet. And
what's important is that a person clean
himself to a reasonable degree.
a lot of
people
are under the misunderstanding
that
a person has to use water
that if you do not use water
then you have not cleaned yourself. This
is incorrect. The reason we have this
misunderstanding
or many of us have this misunderstanding
is because we have water so abundantly.
We have water everywhere. Water in the
restroom. We have water running in our
pipes and so it becomes accessible and
easy and no doubt water is better.
However,
it is not absolutely necessary for a
person to clean or purify himself.
Often times, the prophet sallallah.aii
was use something dry stones, rocks
or something as long as it's not
something that is harmful. And we will
discuss that inshallah.
[Silence]
Muslim.
here and narrates that the messenger of
Allah
when going to relieve himself presumably
in Medina in the times when he was in
Medina he would go to purify himself and
it says myself and another young boy
of my age of similar age we would carry
with us a small bucket of water
and a small spear. And we would go
and accompany him to the outskirts in
order for him to relieve himself. So we
understand the small water, the small
container of water. But why is he taking
a spear with him? Alaz an in the Arabic
language is a short spear. In English,
we call it a lance, right? And it
usually is tooththed. It has a
serrations on on the end. And it's
usually used for close quarters
combat with a shield. Also, alaza can
be used on occasion with someone who
is very skilled with it for hunting as
well. So, it's a lance to use to throw
from horseback or to you be used in
tandem with a shield. Why is he taking
this with him? To relieve himself
when he's relieving himself for what?
Snakes. I mean, that's reasonable,
right? You do have snakes, scorpions,
pests out there or for protection.
That's very correct. It is presumably
for what it is used for. That's why he
would take it with him.
Especially at night going out there in
the dark in the desert, there's monsters
out there. So, they would take
something with them.
This is a one narration of a couple of
narrations that mention that he would
often carry a lance or have a lance
carried for him as well if he planned to
make salah. He would put it in front of
him as a
when he would go to pray.
But the point of the narration, the
spirit of the narration, the reason that
the author mentioned it in this place is
to articulate that the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam when he had access
to water would go out of his way to use
water.
But it is not absolutely critical.
person can use anything else that is dry
and pure and purifying as long as it's
not something that will be you know
of harm to any other creatures.